police in greece have launched a manhunt
after a veteran crime reporter was shot
dead outside his home in athens
jorgos carivas was ambushed and shot
several times as he arrived home from
work
investigators say the shooting looks
like the work of professional
killers it was described as an
execution-style murder
flowers mark the spot where well-known
greek journalist
yogos caravas was killed by several
gunshots in front of his apartment in
athens
caravas was on his way home from a
midday broadcast
when two men on a motorbike drew up
alongside him
and opened fire they killed him without
a sound
which is why police think they were
using a silencer
the country's journalism community is in
shock
no one will stop investigative
journalism in athens or all of greece
we call on the authorities to find the
culprits and lead them to justice
as a veteran crime reporter caravas is
likely to have made some enemies
he worked for the private channel star
tv
but while firebomb attacks and vandalism
on journalists
offices are not unusual in greece murder
is rare
and european officials are keen to make
sure perpetrators are caught and brought
to justice
european commission president ozola
fonderline
wrote on twitter murdering a journalist
is a despicable
cowardly act europe stands for freedom
and freedom of press may be the most
sacred of all
journalists must be able to work safely
the council of europe commissioner for
human rights dunya miyatovic also
treated her concern
the killing of yorgos karavas in greece
today is a tragic reminder that
journalism is a dangerous profession in
europe
colleagues of karevas said he had not
received any death threats
authorities are investigating the
killing but all they know so far
is that the murder was clearly well
planned the work of professionals